je ris
dehors pendant que mon cœur flotte dans
l'océan de larmes
oui tu connais certains de mes amis, j'ai
dégueulé l'autre
jour, nous nous sommes assis et avons parlé, nous avons eu quelques
B, ils sont là Dieu pour ta mère
bébé, je leur ai dit que tu resterais avec  elle
pendant qu'elle était
là et je leur ai aussi dit que tu serais à la maison
dès qu'elle irait
mieux, sucre, je sais que tu le feras,
mon cœur qui se noie s'envole avec
le
ti, je ne sais pas longtemps, je tiens ça
H, je suis assis  voici mon téléphone, je sais que
tu vas appeler et dire que tu
rentres à
la maison, n'est-ce pas
bébé, je suis assis ici sur mon téléphone, je sais que
tu vas appeler et dire que tu
rentres à la maison,
ouais,
le message que tu m'as laissé est  je dois me
tromper, c'est St, il faut y aller
oui et quoi, mais depuis combien de temps Tu
attends juste une chance de faire tes
valises et de partir, il
doit y avoir une erreur ou
quelque chose comme ça, je ne
comprends pas, comment as-tu pu sortir  et j'ai
gâché tous mes
plans mais je sais à l'intérieur mais c'est
vrai ce n'est pas toi qui avais besoin de moi c'est
moi qui avais besoin de
toi assis ici près de mon téléphone je sais que
tu vas appeler pour dire que tu vas
le ramener à la maison  ouais, n'est-ce pas bébé, qu'est-ce que
mon homme
ici te veut,
je l'apporte, tu ne sais pas,
je t'aime, je t'aime, je t'aime, je t'aime, je t'aime, je t'aime, je t'aime,
hé, assieds-toi,
maman, maman,
pH, amène-le, je l'apporte  sur Apportez-le à la
maison